[Music]
okay so there is this story where
Wolverine gets the adamantium torn out
of his body and it is an amazing story
it's the overarching stories called
fatal attractions this is like one
moment in that story and it's really the
only thing anybody ever remembers nobody
ever remembers anything else from fatal
attractions you walk up to anybody and
you're like hey have you ever read fatal
attractions and like yeah that's the
story where Wolverine got his adamantium
whipped out by Magneto right and you're
like yes that's what it was it had other
stuff but other you know whatever that's
cool that you remember anyway it's it's
like it's like the 1990s comic book
story so the whole concept of Wolverine
having his adamantium torn out dates all
the way back to the 1970s in like 1938
Superman debuted and action colonization
of a1 he originally appeared in 1933 and
then he was made into the superhero that
we all know in 1934 if anybody tells me
I'm wrong I'm right you're wrong I
literally wrote a book on the entire
history of Superman do not challenge my
knowledge on that so uh
Superman's popularity takes the world by
storm people are like oh my god like
Superman is so cool it's so awesome
comic books explode and just being sold
everywhere left and right you got the
Justice League in 1960 you got like all
these different things that are
happening now during this entire time
comic books were worth whatever a person
would would buy them from you for that
phrase does that make any sense anyway
um if you lived in a small town that had
like a hundred people there was no
demand for comic books and so if you
tried to sell it the comic book store
owner if you would even buy it would buy
it for like twenty bucks but if you
lived in a great big city like Los
Angeles where there's all different
kinds of people most of which are crazy
they would be like the store owner would
be like hey there's a lot of people that
live here somebody will buy it may be
more than one person will want to buy it
I will buy it from you for like a
thousand bucks all right this was the
standard it was just however much you
could sell it for it but in 1970 a guy
named Overstreet who was a comic book
fan said hey what if there was like a
national standard for the value of comic
books and so he created something called
the Overstreet price guide and what it
did is it basically took an account of
all the comics that were being sold by
coming book companies as well as the
comics that were within individual comic
book stores and it assigned values to
them for example because
as Superman debuted in Action Comics
issue number one that comic was very
rarely found in good condition by the
time 1970 came around and so that comic
was worth a lot of money if it was in
good condition on the other hand
Spiderman debuted an amazing fantasy
number 15 in 1962 and so because it was
only eight years before the price guide
was made there were a lot of comics that
were in good condition of amazing
fantasy issue number 15 so it was worth
less than actually comics issue number
one now because of this national
standard people sat down and they said
hey if I buy a comic now that is
interesting or it's weird like Isis on
Infinite Earths in 1985 in like 20 years
it'll be worth like thousands and
thousands of dollars we were so much
money well that's a great idea if one
person does it it's a bad idea if
millions of people do it and that's what
happened millions of people got together
and they started buying a ton of comic
books this trick'd kelly book creators
are comfortable companies into believing
that the comic book industry was just on
the rise they didn't they didn't realize
that it was like one person buying ten
issues they thought it was ten people
buying one issue and so because of this
they just sort of flooding the market
with comic books they said hey comic
books are popular let's just keep making
more now because of this whole issue
ultimately when it comes to the idea of
supply and demand the more of something
that exists the less valuable that thing
becomes for example the autograph of
Stan Lee Stan Lee's autograph is worth a
ton of money in the 1960s but because
Stan Lee is almost done with all his
living his signature is not worth as
much as it used to be because us
everywhere and so this is what happened
with the comic book industry because of
the fact that there were so many comics
being sold comics didn't have the value
they used to have and so people just
stopped buying them well because people
stopped buying them the industry started
losing money hand over fist hence the
reason Marvel sold the rights to their
movies in the late 1990s now with Marvel
on the verge of filing for bankruptcy
they said we have to find a way to make
our comics interesting to get people to
buy them and so they said we don't do
like reboots we don't do line wide
reboots like DC does which they should
have done with Secret Wars but they're
like we do not do that we do soft reboot
which is kind of like recreate
characters in a different way and so
they said what if we had an event
whereby it allowed us to get rid of the
Avengers in the Fantastic Four as we
know them now because their comics
aren't selling Andrea
imagine them in a different way hence
the onslaught saga which gave us hue as
reborn with Franklin Richards brought
Fantastic Four and the Avengers back to
life and it was they were different than
the way they were before but the fact
remains that fatal attractions led into
the onslaught saga where it allowed
Marvel to achieve this now during this
event fatal attractions there of course
was magneto and Magneto was kind of cool
whatever the fans weren't really feeling
the whole idea of him leading the x-men
and so when Marvel launched x-men vol 2
issue number 1 which was written by
Chris Claremont and drawn by Jim Lee and
it's one of the greatest runs of all
time for the 18 issues that they were
part of it it was basically magneto
returning to his mean roots just hanging
out being a dick doing villains stuff
and like 1964 with expedition number 5
Marvel introduced asteroid M and
asteroid M came and went it was blown up
it was recreated and that pattern just
continued over the years and years and
years that the x-men had been around and
so with x-men vol 2 issue number 1
Marvel was like asteroid M is gone and
magneto has is believed to have died
during the fall of asteroid M but in
truth he was actually alive not only
that he had acolytes
which were basically Magneto's version
of the Four Horsemen of apocalypse and
so magneto was like yes acolytes like we
need to go do bad guy stuff because
we're bad guys and that's what we do uh
let's just let's wreak havoc and so like
magneto is like you know what we're
going to do like we're going to create a
safe haven on on Avalon which is a ship
that he's using that previously belonged
to cable the cable used to time travel
back and forth through time and he says
this is going to be a safe haven for
those of you guys who saw the x-men the
animated series episode called sanctuary
that is based on this story and so
magneto is like yes we're going to hang
out here and then we're going to blow up
earth we're going to wipe out earth
we're gonna kill all the all the humans
and then mutants are gonna be the only
ones left
of course he goes to Charles Xavier and
he's like hey man do you want to be part
of my cool my you know Clubhouse where
only mutants are allowed and it gave you
is like no man that's not cool I don't
want to be part of your Clubhouse I like
humans humans are our friends like they
love us and you know Magneto's like yeah
sure if I love you mean hate then yes
humans love us and so he's like I'm not
going to you know exam he's like I'm not
going to be a part of that and so my
Dino's like okay fine
so monito goes to Avalon
then because of the fact that he's
threatening to destroy the earth the
entire whole of humanity is like do we
got to do something so they launched
something called the Magneto protocols
and the Magneto protocols was basically
humanity's like doomsday scenario like
what happens if magneto just goes off
the rails like he's doing right now and
he wants to just wipe out humans in
their entirety so they blanket the
entire planet in this field where
magneto can't use his powers
hashtag comic-book logic magneto does
use his powers and he basically wipes
out the shield generator thing that
humanity is currently using now because
of this and because of everything that's
going on because there was a severe
called a legacy virus whatever Colossus
younger sister Illyana Rasputin had died
and so because of the fact that she had
died he became disillusioned with Xavier
stream he was basically just angry
lashing out of the world
he joins Magneto that's important keep
that in the back of your head so um
while all this is happening the x-men
are like okay hey guys we got to do
something so we pick up with x-men issue
number 25 and Cyclops is like all right
dude guys like magneto is is back to
being a jerk again we got to find some
way to defeat him and so he's like I
have a plan because I'm Cyclops and I
always have a plan I'm a plot device so
he says let's go into Avalon and let us
like infiltrate the ship and let's take
out Magneto so we can't wage war against
humanity he's going to have his own
enemies we can take them down because
we're the x-men and we have a really
cool theme song
[Music]
and so the external like yeah sure
whatever man we just do whatever you
tell us to just tell us where to go and
we'll go there and do that thing and
we'll be home in time for cornflakes and
so you know Cyclops is like yes okay
cool let's do this so they're all
putting on their suits well then in
Charles Xavier shows up and he's like
hey guys check this out
I can walk man and we're like how are
you able to walk like isn't your whole
niche that you cannot walk and that
that's that you like you have a
wheelchair you cannot put one leg in
front of the other and move in a forward
direction and he's like yeah but I'm
using Shiar technology whatever plot
device so he's able to walk and so they
all go to Avalon and and they're like
okay look magneto man you can't do this
or you can't be doing this this kind of
stuff like you can't be you know waging
war against humanity you can't be you
know trying to kill folks and things
like that that's not cool man
and magneto is like whatever alright
like either you get off here I'm gonna
kill all you guys
well then Wolverines like bar I'm
Wolverine like all I do is attack stuff
because I'm just a mindless character
that nobody's known how to write very
well since Chris Claremont left the
title and so he's like I'm going to just
attack Magneto
and like magneto was like dude your
bones are literally covered in metal
this is the worst thing you could have
done the most boneheaded move in the
history of the world and so he's like
I'm gonna show you why it's a boneheaded
move and so he's like you know what I'm
tired of you x-men getting in the way
like I'm tired of you x-men just causing
problems for me like let this be a
lesson to you please go forward from
this event understanding your place and
the bigger picture and so we just like
rips the adamantium out of Wolverine
just like pulling it out of it Wolverine
just like oh I'm screaming and so he's
just like in severe pain and the x-men
are just like oh my god and so Xavier is
like okay look you know what Magneto
I've had enough man I'm so tired of you
you know being all emo like you're
getting aggro on Wolverine
you're just being a rude guy man like
you're just you're the guy that nobody
wants to invite to a party and this is
why man nobody invites you to the
cookouts at the Xavier mansion because
you're ripping people's adamantium out
of their bodies and so Xavier is like
I'm gonna shut your mind down so he
literally just goes into the mind
of Magneto and just like shuts that
off he's just like you're done man like
you are you're done that's it like your
mind is shut down now the whole reason
why this matters and whole reason why
this leads into the onslaught saga is
because what Xavier didn't know was that
shortly after this there would be
mutants who were killed just killed in
plain sight like humanity would wage war
against mutants like no other largely
because of the actions of magneto they
just basically let mutants have it it
wasn't like an all-out war it was like
guerrilla warfare tactics and like hate
groups but because of this Xavier just
became increasingly frustrated with
humanity he was like why can't they just
be cool man like why can't they just
chill you know at the same time he had
actually absorbed the mind of Magneto
when he shut his mind down and so
magneto was like I hate humanity like
screw these guys man like they're just
mean man like they're just mean people
and so these two things merged into a
singular entity which is festered in the
mind of Xavier and like subconsciously
emerged periodically without Xavier
knowing and that's where the onslaught
entity came from which led into the
onslaught saga oh by the way the really
important thing here this is actually a
really really big deal too is like no
one ever knew about this like they never
knew about about Wolverines claws
beforehand all we ever knew was that his
claws were just adamantium like he just
popped his claws and I was like yeah
let's just cut through everything except
Captain America shield because it's
Captain America his shield is made out
of American Progress America so he is
he's like we didn't know that he could
do that that he had like bone claws but
because of this story we found out that
he actually had bone claws that his
claws were made of bone and this was a
really big deal because what this did
with Wolverine is it set him off on his
own story where he became feral
Wolverine he literally just ran into the
woods like a crazy and was just
living there for a while he was just he
was like wild man Jack just living in
the woods like Grizzly Adams and just
hanging out there and he was he looked
really really cool too like he was
pretty badass the way he looked like if
I saw Wolverine like feral Wolverine in
the woods I would be like dude it's time
to go man like we need to not be here
because he's going to really like cut us
to pieces this is this is a scariest
thing I've ever seen so like it was it
was a really cool thing but anyway guys
yeah so this is the rundown of how
Wolverine had his adamantium torn out of
his body I hope you guys enjoyed it and
yeah um post comments down below let me
know what you guys think my next rundown
topic should be make it something
interesting don't pick something obscure
nobody wants to see a rundown video on
something something obscure anyway I
will catch you guys on your piece